what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I just
tell you my sporadic thoughts for the
day what I'm doing that week while I
drink coffee except I quit coffee but
what I love about you guys the guys that
watch my morning coffee thoughts is that
you guys hold me accountable
so yesterday
I went to Panera I got myself a sandwich
and a chai tea and you guys were like
you're trying to lose weight why are you
eating that and I was like
they're right why am I eating that
foreign
now is this better guys it's zero
calories it's still got caffeine in it
it's not really the reason I quit coffee
wasn't really about the caffeine it was
about the sugar
um but I guess if I drink chai tea it's
the same thing maybe
I need to cut chai tea next
put in the comments what can I get from
Starbucks in the morning maybe I should
just learn to drink water I don't know
I do drink water but I just like I don't
know why I've just always like drinking
something that's not
um okay
so this week I've been hanging out with
the family
um
I really
I've been asked to do interviews and I
get asked like you guys are always
asking me to go on your podcasts and I'm
sorry I'm just not trying to film while
I'm home I am tired I filmed so much in
Florida and I was like sick and I just
did way too many podcasts this trip to
the point like a lot of you guys were
come saying oh Pearl like she doesn't
say anything on these podcasts and I'm
like guys I was just so tired
like when I was on with um freaking
Destiny everyone wanted me to come in so
heated and hot I'm like guys I did three
podcasts in one day I'm exhausted
and they don't tell you the topics
before you get on so it's kind of like
you know anyways
so so this week
I've spent a lot of time with my
youngest sister so her name's Amelia and
Amelia
is really cute so she's always been my
like I call her my gamer sister and she
doesn't really
how do I put it sometimes over the years
she's kind of lack the ambition
for certain things but recently she's
been really trying at basketball and
she's actually getting pretty good
and I'm just like oh my gosh I'm so
proud of her see I'll go to the games
and I'll be like that's my sister and
Amelia acts like
she acts like she doesn't like it she's
like oh you're so embarrassing
she likes it she likes it I'll tell you
what so this week she told me I could
coach her next year
because we gotta work on her post game
okay I was a center and the thing was I
was kind of one of those centers like I
wasn't that quick on my feet but like
I used to knock girls over posting up
and boxing out I guys okay I'm gonna
show you I would I was teaching her you
gotta go like this you gotta handle
handle the screen and you go boom boom
and you like
you got an elbow you got it sorry you
guys probably this wasn't a good
depiction but I was like you got an
elbow because my little sister I'm built
a little bit more muscular she's a bit
thinner right and
they kept pushing around my sister
I was like I swear to God I'll hit it oh
Auntie said I gotta stop swearing but I
was like I will hit one of these girls
because they kept pushing her around and
I'm like Amelia you can't let them push
you around I swear to when I was in high
school they could not do that to me they
could not because I will knock your ass
look it
this is why I said I was raised like a
tomboy oh my gosh
I was aggressive I got a couple personal
fouls
like basketball is the one thing where I
would I would get mad like I'm very easy
going you guys have seen But like when a
girl is being aggressive towards me and
basketball oh no or the refs just keep
calling Falls for no reason
one time I'll tell you this time I got a
personal phone
because
the rap kept calling falls on me and I
wasn't Fallen it's just like the tall
girl let's just put him on the tall girl
so I was straight up and so I had the
ball and I and I was about to slam it
and I realized what I was doing I'm like
no you can't do that and I kind of
slammed it but it was like a weak slam
and they still give me a technical I'm
like he was just he my mom said he had
short man syndrome because
sorry I'm sorry to my short bed but you
know that that saying they say like the
short men are angry because they're
short and my mom was just like
yeah he was just mad because he couldn't
reach the ball
ah okay I was like a tall guy that would
have just been a pass
but I was trying to think of like I
really don't want to move to Chicago
because like the taxes are high
it's a nice city but like there's winter
there's not really anyone in my field
here
but my parents are here and I really
like my parents but the thing is I could
move to Chicago
and what would happen my one my youngest
sister is gonna move out
in a year
my other sister that's home a lot
might go to school in New York but she
goes to school like she's in college my
my second youngest sister you guys have
seen her on the channel a couple times
Eva
um
she might go to school in New York my
brothers that are here which are Adam
and Chaz they are in their like early
20s and they work for my dad so that's
why they they stay here but it's kind of
like you don't I could come here and I
don't even know if they're gonna be here
I know my sister well I was like can I
go to Chicago for a year but then I'm
gonna move everything just to go here
for a year
but I don't know it's just so nice I
really like being here
but then sometimes you get close to your
parents and you know you're like you
know what
never mind this was close enough
but um
I don't know
being home like just makes me very happy
like I just love being home
and even if I'm not like spending all
day hanging out with the family like
just knowing they're in the house and I
can like walk down the hall and ask some
questions just
I loved living at home it's unfortunate
I was so encompassed in this
relationship that I was in at the time
where I didn't spend as much time at
home as like I would have like with that
boyfriend we went to like La for like
three months and I was like supporting
his thing in LA and
um it's hard because you know like on
the principle
you know I'm I guess I'm not mad I
followed him and like was always with
him and whatever
um and I think it taught me some lessons
um however sometimes I really regret not
spending as much time with my family
that year because it was kind of like
the last time
I'm gonna say the last time I could do
that but like it like there's four of my
siblings in the house
um
and sometimes I don't know it's just
like you don't you can't really recreate
that like everyone's leaving they're all
gonna be gone everyone's gonna have
their own families so
um
yeah I don't know sometimes I just I
wish I I maybe spent a bit more time
with my family that year but sometimes
when I get like engrossed in a
relationship I just get like very I
don't know
um
but yeah that's that's the
what I was trying to think and then I
was thinking I was like baby baby
I could have shows for three months and
then go coach her for three months and
do documentaries here so we have the
business in like Tennessee or NE or Nash
or um Miami and then I could come I
don't know I was or I'm telling you guys
I was thinking of all these ways who
knows I stole my she was like I'll play
Club if you coach I was like
because I told my sister she needs one
year of aau's my sister okay
she is really good like she's a lot
quicker than I was like she's quicker
feet and her defense phenomenal I was so
proud of her like she doesn't even get
the Falls called on her because she just
is so good at going straight up
however my little sister's afraid to
shoot and I kept telling her your team
would stop losing by 20 if you started
dropping 20 every game like that's what
you got to do sis
and I was like because
yeah you just gotta start getting the
rebounds and going up because you're
you're her guards always miss they just
miss all their shots I'm like you have
to get the rebounds and just go right up
with it you're taller she's almost
taller than me and at first I was mad I
was like I need to be the tallest girl
in the family I need to be the tallest
girl but now that I'm one of her
basketball fans I'm like okay you can
outgrow me you can be taller it's like a
okay it's funny in the manosphere
it's like a negative if women are tall I
don't want to say a negative like some
guys like tall girls and most guys don't
really care if you're hot you're hot
they're down but
they they always say like oh it's like
unfortunate if a girl is tall and I
agree dating wise it really is however
in my family we have like a competition
so like my next youngest sister
Gabrielle I thought she was gonna
outgrow me everyone said she'd outgrow
me she didn't
she did not now Amelia is taller than
Gabrielle she is real close it is like
like
if she's with the thing is she's 16
and most girls are done growing by 16
but she's still going so
she might be like six one six two she's
getting tall
so
I don't know I guess I guess we'll see I
guess we'll see
but I don't know this man guys I'm so
sporadic about where to move I'm like
thinking
oh I could I could go to Chicago
I do Chicago is a nice city it's clean I
like the roads here oh my God I hate the
roads in Florida I hate driving on
y'all's Road maybe I'm just
I hated the roads okay Miami I haven't
checked out Nashville yet I'm leaving to
go back to the UK Tuesday so I think I'm
gonna check out Nashville
um
when I come back in March but
Miami was really clean
the restaurants were really nice uh for
what I do it's actually nice how late
everything's open
um
a lot of people in my space of YouTube
go there
so I think it would be easy to like get
guests
um
however it's a lot of traffic a lot of
traffic
um apparently I would hate the Summers
because it gets stupid hot I kind of
liked the humidity I was like oh this is
nice and the weather oh my gosh the Sun
it just makes you happy Nashville
I was looking up the weather it's like a
warmer more mild version of here
so I wouldn't have to deal with the
stupid cold winters like Chicago I hate
Chicago winners
oh my gosh and the thing about Florida
that makes me want to go there is
like I think Nashville the city would
suit me the best like if I just pick
City I love country music
um I think there's there seems like I
could live in the suburbs and not live
in directly downtown and still get to
the city again I love country music
however
Miami my parents have a house in Miami
and I think I would see my family a bit
more because they a lot of my family
goes to our Florida house and it's like
two hours from
from Miami so I could just drive there
I don't know
I really just want to coach my sister I
was like how can I pull this off
basketball's such a long season I wish
it was volleyball because volleyball is
like three months so you could do it
three months figure it out basketball
goes on forever oh my gosh it's like
half the year and if you do a use it's
even longer
and I've never coached
I've never coached you there's a lot of
money in coaching but
in my head I was just like well I'd
rather work out if I have to spend two
hours in a gym every day like why don't
I just work out and get a good body like
I don't have enough time to do both but
I actually think I'd be a good coach I
really like
working with kids
I'm so proud of her anyways
um
that's my morning coffee thought so let
me know in the comments what where
should I move I don't know guys I'm all
over the place let me know
help me help me get on this healthy
Journey
I have not been working out like
traveling always sets me back I do so
good when I'm in the UK and then I
travel
and I do bad and then I go to my mom's
house and the food is so good here
but let me know in the comments like the
video subscribe to the channel I'll talk
to you next time